Okay.
Hey, Natalie.
Do you?
How's life?
Life is good so far.
Surviving.
That's good. That's good. Is it getting weird in India at all?
with like everything going on.
It is, but yeah, not much impact.
Just another day. Just another day in this world, you know.
To everyone, yes, just another day.
Yeah.
Yes.
Has Dylan registered for the build ITBD or not yet?
He hasn't, so yeah, I'm gonna ask him.
Mm.
Kaila.
Not yet.
Last time he did like the AI accelerator he did mention.
Yeah, exactly. So as long as I know they go to a lot of events as well, so as long as there's no event conflict, hopefully they'll come.
Kip, I bought the new keyboard and it already broke on me, like it just isn't working anymore, so now I'm back, I'm back to just like using my laptop again. It's so frustrating.
Yeah.
And like I even like switched off the batteries and it just like isn't connecting.
Of.
Did you buy it on sale or?
I got from Target. No, I think I was right from Prince.
Yeah, Tanner is there.
Hey, Tanner, how are you?
Doing well, Kip. How are you today?
I'm doing good.
I have Natalie with me today.
Prince.
Hey, now.
Yes. Hey, Deirdre.
Awesome.
Yeah, kick it off, Kip. I don't got anything for you.
Yeah, yeah, so how's it going? How have you been so far? It's been just Tuesday, but...
It's been busy. It's been busy. Yeah, we've had a busy last couple weeks, so.
Yeah.
Oh, OK.
Keith.
How's Casey's doing?
He's doing well. He's been on a lot of project work. We've had a company that's kind of...
having some issues with Microsoft products and Azure and everything. And so he's been doing a lot of monitoring and working with companies with project work like that. Still doing a lot of onboarding with our new email security that we implemented the last couple months. And so, yeah, he's been not short of tickets, that's for sure.
Mhm.
But things are going good. Yeah, we're happy with everything.
Okay, great. Anything you want to share? Any suggestion? Here is an improvement.
No, I think he knows exactly what we would like him to do. Yeah, he's he's learning our system more and more every month, so it's going good.
Okay.
Okay, great.
I guess then we can quickly jump into the presentation. Let me share my screen real quick. Let's have a look at his numbers on the last month. Let me know once you are able to see my screen.
I can see it.
Okay, so welcome to our monthly business review and this is from April 20th till May 15th.
And agenda would be the same. Started with check-in, highlights, action tracker, performance analysis, various software customer, way forward, and recap.
We already discussed about how Casey is doing and thank you for sharing the feedback.
We really appreciate it. And moving on to the highlights, so Casey has been performing well and he's consistent proactive engagement and ownership of assigned work. He's been actively handing tickets while supporting the project activities as well, including the email security migration as you mentioned.
He's effectively balancing the project work and the tickets and independently managing and handling the onboarding tasks. We also discussed about the KPI framework. I shared some KPIs for the project engineer role. Did you get a chance to
To check with Dylan.
I can mark it down to check with Dylan. I did not though.
Okay.
Okay, no problem.
I will put it down.
Okay, thank you.
And also, thank you so much for sharing the feedback for the month of April, Casey.
And moving on to the action tracker. So the first one is again the to identify the KPIs that still to be determined. And then certification and training on AZ104, that's on Casey and he's on track with that. He is possibly going to complete it by the end of May.
Sweet.
So, it's on track, and these are the KPIs I shared with you regarding the project engineer, so I will share this PPT once we are done with this call, and you can check the Dylan on the same.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
And jumping into the performance analysis, this is his utilization for the last four weeks. It's been pretty consistently close to 66%. The last week was hit a high of 122%.
Hoh.
And in the third week, he was on 2 planned videos. That's why it went down.
Any question on this, Tanya?
Looks too far, looks good.
Okay, cool. Moving on to the ticket data, that is...
You can see it's aligned with the utilization in the last, in the 4th week, the tickets were high and he worked on 116 tickets signed those four weeks and closed 37.
And that includes migrations, infra changes, and the projects and everything.
And, way forward, Casey to reach out whenever he has less tickets to work on, and I hope he is doing the same.
Yeah, he has been, yeah, he reaches out when necessary and it's just, yeah, lately I don't think he's been short on tickets. So it's been.
And this is, yep.
Yep.
And good.
OK, and this is Build It Live 2026. Natalie, do you want to take over?
Yeah, Tanner, are you guys going to any events the first week of August? I know there's a few out there right now, but we'd love to have you at our event. And then we're also doing the last day is going to be like another AI accelerator. So I know Dylan liked that last time as well. So that's included in our event this year.
Okay, possibly. I know the third week of August we are.
somewhere, but I don't think we are that weak. I could check with Dylan and see.
Okay, yeah, I'll send you, and then I have a BOGO code for you guys too, so you can get 2 tickets. It's going to be cool. We're doing, there's a Pre Day on Sunday, so if you guys want to sample like the peer groups, we're doing that on the Sunday before Build It, so that'll be the 2nd. And then our offsite's going to be at the New York Stock Exchange, and we're going to have like a Great Gatsby party, so it'll be fun.
Ohh, cool.
Yeah.
Very cool. Yeah, send us some information on it. Definitely something we...
Possibly be interested in, yeah.
Thank you.
Okay, so moving on to the AI by design, that's again the part of the AI accelerator. And this is the team GPS, our in-house built-in tool.
Reid.
And yeah, that's the recap I'm going to send you at the end of this email. And that's it.
Anything else you want to share or suggest?
I don't think so. I think things are running smooth.
Just give us a, for Casey's days off, just give us a heads up on those. So we have more than a day or two when he's going to be out of the office for two days. But typically that hasn't been an issue. I think it just, yeah, got forgot about. But yeah, no, as long as we get a heads up when he's out in the office, that's great.
Yep.
Yeah, sure, sure. Definitely I will keep that in mind and yeah, we'll keep you updated beforehand like a week or two.
Pre.
That's perfect.
Yep, anything from you, Natalie?
No, I'm good on my side. Thanks, Kip.
All right, thank you, Tina, for joining this call today, and have a wonderful rest of the day. Bye.
Awesome.
Yeah, thank you guys.
Thanks, Tina.
You too. Bye.